monsieur mulcair au scrabble niqab est
un monde de 14 points qui vous en oeuvre
c'est vrai que ça pourrait en effet
perdre autant dans les intentions de
vote au québec depuis que le
gouvernement conservateur veut dire
qu'ils légifèrent et pour interdire aux
femmes musulmanes de porter le niqab
dans les cérémonies de citoyenneté
qu'ils avaient pris la position inverse
et le niqab qui seraient portés par un
peu près 50 femmes au québec est devenue
l'enjeu majeur de la campagne électorale
êtes vous tombé dans le piège qu'elle
conseillait as trahi et de stephen
harper vous attendu vous savez c'est une
arme de distraction massive pour
monsieur repris peut essayer de cacher
son bilan
derrière un niqab tout le monde sent un
certain réserve
les gens sont inconfortables avec ça
qu'ils y compris moi-même quand j'ai vu
que la première fois des mamans qui
était en niqab avec les enfants c'est
vrai que certaines mais on est là pour
respecter les tribunaux aussi et je
pense qu'à un moment donné quand des
tribunaux statuent et il faut dans une
société basée sur la primauté du doigt
les respecter mais vous poser la bonne
question ça profite à qui
cette histoire là il fait ça pourquoi
maintenant main sur un peu il avait dix
ans pour régler le problème si vraiment
il doit considérer un problème mais
c'est pas du hasard je crois que ça
tombe en prémices d'une campagne qu'il a
pris son problème et c'est devenu le
veau c'est correct aussi une bonne
stratégie de sa part
non je trouve ça honteux mais c'est pas
grave si je suis capable de répondre
parce que je comprends que les gens
sentent ce malaise je partage ce malaise
vis-à-vis du niqab mais je crois aussi
qu'on doit avoir le respect des
tribunaux et je crois aussi que la
plupart des gens commencent à comprendre
que le vrai enjeu du 19 octobre
c'est pas ça c'est un gouvernement
guerrier pollueurs fermé qui projette un
traitement des images est ce que voulait
augmenter l'âge de la retraite est ce
que vous voulez un impérial sur le pont
champlain est ce que vous voulez votre
service de courrier à domicile
est ce que vous les sabres et à
radio-canada ça c'est le vrai bilan de
stephen harper reste ça que moi je
repars et jusqu'au 19 octobre